i was there in six and a half days lord
knows i wanted to get out
i learned a psych ward jesse smallett is
going into detail about his experience
in a psychiatric ward following the
actor's court sentencing i am innocent i
did not do this in december jesse was
found guilty on five counts of
disorderly conduct for his role in lying
to law enforcement about a staged attack
against himself and in march jesse was
sentenced to 150 days in jail and if
anything happens to me when i go in
there
i did not do it to myself an appeals
court later ordered jesse to be released
on bond pending the appeal of his
conviction but not before jesse spent
nearly a week behind bars as i'm sitting
in there i'm like i know that i didn't
do this while appearing on siriusxm sway
in the morning jesse describes his
experience in cook county jail there's
something about being in there and
having no choice but to surrender
surrender not to
the system but you're surrendering to
yourself and you're surrendering to
you're just left there with you your
thoughts
and these walls
as jesse explains his decision to fast
during that time wasn't without reason
i fasted i was there for six and a half
days i fasted for six and a half days i
wasn't fasting for lent i was fasting
because
that's what we do
in my family like we fast
for
for clarity what i was doing is i was
fasting until i found out whether or not
i was going to be in there for those
five and a half months yeah looking to
the future jesse says he's focused on
reviving his career what i know for sure
is
every single thing that i auditioned for
during that period i lost
they took it from me
but every single thing that i created
myself
that's being created has been created
never again will anybody be able to pull
my life from under me like a rug as
jesse's legal team works on his appeal
he continues to profess his innocence if
i had done something like this
it would mean that i stuck my fist in
the pain of black americans in this
country for over 400 years didn't need
to have a
some sort of
rise in his career but people are going
to believe what they believe and what i
have to do is
i have to keep working in addition to
jail time jesse was sentenced to 30
months of felony probation and ordered
to pay 120 thousand dollars in
restitution
the prison system needs to be dismantled
you have to be a a different kind of
person to really
search and
try to find the redemption in this
that place is not meant for redemption
yeah that place is not meant to make you
come out better than when you went in
[Music]